hello everybody hope they are good what
a move for Bitcoin eh wow I mean it's a
12% pump in just 24 hours it's amazing
usually these moves take uh two or 3
Days To to happen but that's the
importance of momentum guys okay um
yesterday in both Twitter and also in
the telegram channel in different
moments of the day I was telling you to
to no short because the momentum was
very strong you need to wait for
momentum to save it out and that usually
takes a few hours right now yesterday's
projection was to favor higher prices
same as on Sunday with the Bitcoin
Sunday update on Twitter and in
yesterday this video on Monday evening I
was telling you that I was going to
favor higher prices time to favor Longs
for the simple reason that when you are
ins set a range and you see a sweep of
the lows like this you have a very clear
support here that has been tested and
didn't sweep the lows then if price
comes back again to that level the most
likely thing is that it sweeps the lows
take all those stop losses from traders
that are opening Longs from this area
and that they are placing their stop
losses right below this this support
take those stop losses and then move to
the upside towards the range highs so uh
we also have here this weak and false
move to the upside that created a CME
Gap remember and yesterday we had the
retest of the imbalance the imbalance
has been failed and then that's when
price could go up and that's when I told
you that I was going to look for Longs
now I couldn't end enter in this long
because what I was looking is this
candle to close above the 50 ma which it
did but then a retest and if you notice
the momentum started to kick in right at
the start of the New York session go to
the 1 hour time and you're going to see
here at 2 p.m. momentum comes in and
boom it it keeps going up without any
retre so I couldn't enter here at this
stage that obviously I wouldn't have
closed it here I would have closed my
trade I told you yesterday if I enter
there my take profit was going to be a
50 3,000 for the simple reason that at
that level is when we would see a
rejection let me remove all of this
now now in yesterday's video I was also
talking about the scenario to the upside
which would be basically to see some
consolidation Above This High here all
right so if you see some consolidation
around this level then you could favor
higher prices and if you notice that's
the consolidation okay consolidation if
you also notice these are higher lows
all the time so what will you show there
that's what I told you also yesterday in
Twitter guys okay all the liquidation to
the upside has been hit but there is not
a sign of momentum sifting because the
momentum was very strong you can see
with all the scandle so why would you
short there just because price is going
up you don't need to short okay so
that's the first time that uh it would
be a mistake to short that I try to warn
some of you and then also if you go back
to the 1 hour time frame in the next
pump so in this area here I also told
you to not short again this time was in
the telegram channel for the simple
reason that you had this week here and
when there is a we to the upsite it's
telling you the price is very likely to
go back to it how long can it take well
it can take it can be in the next candle
or it can be in the next day but having
that week up there is telling you that
price is going to go back there and it's
very likely that it do it a straight
away in most cases it does go back to
the we straight away so why will you
short that go back to the 15 minutes
time frame that's the area Okay boom
fills the week and continuation no
reason to sort that now what do you see
here well I see another week do you see
that that's a week go back to the 4our
time frame what do you see I see the
same week there two weeks okay in the 4
hours time frame and the 15 minutes time
frame why would you short that you you
know price is very likely to come back
to this level all right so what will you
be taking shorts
here
again you have the same structure higher
lows all the time same as back
there same as here why will you short
it's an uptrend okay there is a lot of
momentum and you can short against
momentum so um I can tell you this
because I've been here before in the
past so I don't make these mistakes
anymore but I used to make them and I'm
sure that some of you watching this
video have made this mistake and it's
not nice to lose money but if you use
your process to learn then you know it
kind of levels out okay so try to learn
from that don't short momentum you have
to be very very selective if you want to
enter a short you have to enter it when
momentum is saf and there is no sign yet
the momentum is sifting all right
because look at this higher lows and
consolidation about the key level the
previous high that means higher then you
have a week that means higher and then
you have another week that means higher
okay and now what well what will you
sure now it's true that there is not to
the upside but price keeps making higher
lows and there is no any sign that
momentum is Shifting out do you see any
sign because I don't okay go back to the
one hour time frame sorry one our time
frame I don't see any sign of momentum
sifting out so why would I enter a short
don't try to enter shorts when there is
an uptrend instead it's better if you
can trade the imbalances to the upside
such as those weeks and this applies to
day traders to scalpers and to swing
Traders okay because in the 15 minutes
time frame you have this week you also
have that week in the 1 hour time frame
you have this week here okay in the four
hours time frame you also have let me
remove that you also have this week here
so if there is an up trint you should
try to trade the trend okay trade the
imbalances that are left behind to the
upside all right now do I see any
imbalance to the upsite not really
because it's true that we have this Weg
here okay that's the week it Go filled
the week went beyond it quite far beyond
it which means that this week here is
valid for the week fill strategy that
week has just been filled so right now
there are no weeks to the upside that
could get filled okay for now you can
only do two things you can gamble and
you can go short or
long or you can wait for a new imbalance
to be created to the upsite Imagine now
at right at the start of the New York
station we see a massive pump over there
but then a retrace that creates a weak
say for example in the 15 minutes time
frame 1 hour time frame 4 hours time
frame trade towards that week because
you can see how that's been paying out
in the last 24 hours we've had a few
weeks that got filled so if we see a
week right at the start of the New York
session try to wors it in the New York
session and if we start to see signs
of momentum sifting out and with that I
mean that I want to see another range
here with weeks to the upside but price
not progressing any further and it's
true that is very likely that you don't
see this in the in the 15 minutes time
frame you are probably if you get to see
that you're going to see that in the 1
hour time frame or in the in the 4 hours
time frame so take this level here and
now if in the next say six seven hours
you start to see weeks to the upside
here but price cannot break break Above
This Zone then perhaps Asia can start to
drop all right that would be the sign of
momentum saf for me until I don't see
weeks to the UPS that price now progress
any
further I'm not going into shorts okay
and again you can apply that to the one
time frame or to the four time frame if
you want to be more careful in my case I
prefer in this case to to keep an eye on
the one hour time frame because
if I start to see this kind of behavior
during the New York session then at this
point here that's day sensation I can
enter a small short okay if price if
price starts to break below these levels
then I can add to my short okay and
write the the way down towards for
example the 1 hour 50 ma all right you
have to be very selective in this type
of volatile environments and I don't
want this to sound like after the no I'm
telling you off or something of course
not you know I have nobody to tell you
off and the most likely thing uh is that
you're going to learn by yourself uh how
to avoid these mistakes because if you
make them then uh you should think about
them and that'll help you to to avoid
them in the future that was my case uh
but if you are starting and this is the
first time or a few times you've made a
mistake and you don't really understand
what has gone wrong then perhaps what
I've been telling you can can help okay
don't trade against momentum you need to
wait for momentum to shift out and the
clear the most clear sign are weeks to
the upside but price not progressing any
further okay the same applies to the
downside Wicks to the downside but price
not progressing any further look are we
in the four time frame no let's go to
the four hour time frame check this out
okay this is what I mean in this area
weeks to the upside price cannot break
through the area that means that the
market maker is building shorts because
momentum is Shifting you have this huge
red candle that you can trade okay that
is the the scalp that you can take for a
reversal but you see this sign that is
what you want to see that's what you
want to see and also especially if it's
at a key level this was for example at
50,000 so what our key level right now
go to the 1 hour time frame well 57,000
is a round number because if you take
this if you take this number here that's
57 7, 73 pretty much 57,000 so seeing
weeks in this area but price not being
able to break through that means that
Asia could pull that red candle and that
can be your short otherwise don't be
looking for shorts right now I'm not in
a position I'm waiting to see what New
York does if New York pushes price up we
see a long week then I'm going to trade
towards that week in a long okay it's
pretty simple try to be selective with
your trades guys and in terms of high
time frame it's pretty much what we've
been saying okay you got two resistances
here you have one a 52,000 and the next
one is a
60,000 um if you notice in this area
here between 52,000 and
60,000 there is no any clear resistance
so if price managed to break Above This
level 52,000 then it's very likely to
see ,000 pump all the way to 60,000
because there is no any resistance on
the way all right so can we say that
Bitcoin is going to go to 60,000 it's
very likely because if you notice we
broke that resistance very clearly um
price is on its way right so Bitcoin to
60,000 yes even if we start to see do we
to the upset in the one hour time frame
and we can manage to take a short take
it that as a scalp because then price is
very likely to push continue higher to
60,000 okay so um don't try to open
swing shorts at this level
because having the high time frame
telling you the weekly time frame that
60,000 is very likely any short that you
are looking to trade it has to be very
selective and it has to be a sculps okay
close them maximum within 24 hours
that's what I recommend you guys because
60,000 seems like it's going to be the
next Target all right be very selective
if you looking to short and if you are
looking too long just look for weeks
it's as simple as that wait for a week
to the upside especially if it can be
done in the New York session because
then it's very likely that it fils it
the straight away in the same session
and that's how you can take uh
opportunism from this type of Market
High Capital liquidation levels let's
have a look first of all the Delta $25
billion worth of long liquidations of
course take this number with a pinch of
salt because it's not real only use it
as a reference I'm using the max
liquidity setting but usually when we
are between 25 and $330 billion worth of
long or short liquidations that's when
we must pay attention to reversal signs
okay so keep an eye on for that for that
sift of momentum because if you see in
the chart then you can use this as a
Confluence to tell you that it's likely
to see a long squee all right so keep an
eye for reversal signs but we are still
very selective because if you check the
spikes at the right of this chart you
can still see some spikes to the upside
are very big okay 57,7 70 and
59,000 so if this continues increasing
say 30 35 billion while price continues
going higher to
59,000 then that is basically telling
you very likely that there is a retrace
at 60k but between 59 and 60k because at
59 you have all these liquidations at
60k you have the high time frame
resistance that we saw a few rejections
in the past and you're also going to
have the Delta liquidations very very
high so a long squeeze would be
necessary at that point okay now if you
the other hand today we start to see
some
consolidation while in the 1 hour time
frame we start to see weeks to the
upside but price not progressing any
further then we can go to the idea in
today's s session that momentum is
Shifting in the market and the market
making might be preparing from shorts a
little retrace a little long squeeze to
liquidate all the late long positions
all right so these are the kind of signs
that I'm going to be paying attention to
today right now I repeat I'm not in a
position I'm only I'm only going to be
watching the New York session that's all
I want to watch okay if they push a
straightway to 59
60k and this continues rising to 30$ 35
billion the Delta then very likely the
price is going to have a long squeeze
longest squeeze is the opposite of a
short squeeze longest squeez is when
there are many Traders positioned in
Longs so Market is going to try to
squeeze them down with a retrace to the
downside to stop all those long
positions okay so that would be to me
the sign pump to 596k while the Delta
goes to 30 $35 billion that's a sign to
me of a retrace and in the other hand if
we see today New York consolidating at
57,000 weeks to the upside price not
progress in F that then keep an eye for
the as session because we we might see a
little retrace okay that's pretty much
everything and of course if New York
sets a week to the upside then trade it
long toward wors it because all the
weeks are getting felt because momentum
so far hasn't been stopping okay it
could start to to to stop now and to St
now but so far momentum is is still very
strong and of course if we see a quick
to the upsite in the New York session
then long towards it okay trade it
because as I've been showing you
momentum so far is not showing any signs
of of stopping and sifting and all the
weeks have been filled all the weeks to
the upside so those are the type of
setups that you can trade in high
volatile moments that are going to be
high probability trades and you're not
going to incur in too much risk so
that's pretty much everything that I
want to say guys ah of course
liquidation hit map very quickly but
I've already have a look at this and
there is nothing really new okay take
this area
nothing really okay we tooking all those
liquidations there some liquidations
form uh 57,000 we also took them some
are starting to form between 60,000 and
62,000 so far this area it's not very
bright because uh there are no many
liquidations up there but I could
already start to tell you that some
Traders are starting to D into shorts
again because when price goes up some
Traders feel the need to also go short
so keep an eye on that because it may be
similar to what we've seen here okay for
now that's it just watch the New York
session I'm going to post today some
updates on Twitter and in the telegram
Channel Through the evening so if I take
a trade in the Asian session or in the
New York session with a week I'll let
you know okay so that's pretty much
everything guys thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you
soon